she's no stranger to talking on these
issues
i am proud to be a woman and a feminist
as a working royal she engaged in ways
that others just couldn't
i am here with you as a mother as a wife
as a woman as a woman of color and as
your sister
[Music]
now megan is calling on other young
women to speak up
something she knows isn't always easy
there will always be negative voices and
sometimes those voices can appear to be
outsized
and sometimes they can appear to be
painfully loud but you can
use your own voice to drown out that
noise
because that's what it is it is just
noise
the keynote speech for the girl up
summit is her most high profile speech
since stepping away from royal life and
the tone at times
felt more political another thing about
those
lawmakers and leaders and executives i
mentioned earlier
now many of them that are worse
they don't listen until they have to
because the status quo
is easy to excuse and it's hard to break
but it will pull tightest right before
snapping
melissa kilby from girl up told me she
is a powerful voice
she has an incredible platform and when
women are using their platforms to
encourage each other
um to be to be role models and even just
in their bravery
i think that platform is incredibly
powerful you know it's it's it is the
words but it is also just the action
of speaking up of being a part of this
conversation and i think
you know that's what i take away and i
think that's really what the girls are
are taking away
you know seeing her choose to be a part
of this conversation
her words about drowning out the noise
couldn't have felt more relevant
not just for the young women fighting
for equality but for a couple who still
have their critics
as they find their feet in their new
life rhiannon mills sky news